so would that happen and so now many
people listen listening to me us right
now think wow well how in God's name did
you resolve your differences that's true
right in it and it was literally the
last thing I wanted to do you know but
I'm glad it happened is it is it true
that when okay let's do this after
Freddie passed yeah you were on the
patio and you said to another comic do
you think Eleanor and I ever resolved
our issues and they said that died with
Freddie soda yeah that was real yeah see
and I always kept that in my head
because that person told me yeah yeah
yeah it's crazy how you can carry that
much of the trail for Eleanor and you're
not even clear about what happened right
like you know it's everything we imagine
our enemies we imagine so many bad
things because you know you're just on
the defense a lot yeah
but it's also years of you it's it's
been so long but I can be cold so it can
come off like yeah cuz when somebody's
that cold and shuts down I'm an ass I
get it she if I don't like you is yeah
it's it's but it's not that you know
what I've discovered since now the last
couple years have been friends how long
has it been it's been over a year though
it's been over yeah you did the podcast
last year last year that was ballsy of
me to ask that was a was at the Comedy
Store about a year ago right in the
basement yeah in the basement and
Eleanor was just hanging out just
finished doing a party yeah and I was
just like when she's around at that
point I was just like I don't care you
know I don't really care but then she
looks at me right and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is the first time in 20 yeah what
the [ __ ] is this this is scary
now you exist she goes hey you wanna do
the podcast what do you do I go yeah I
didn't think about it did you look at
Heidi to see if she was talking through
you and there was I'm not I wouldn't be
surprised if he did because he used to
go to Philadelphia and think I was gonna
have him
I could but it could be here too so when
she said that I couldn't believe my ears
and I immediately said yes because when
you're walking around with that much
[ __ ] garbage luggage car is garbage
luggage it's like you're just wait it's
on your back and you're walking around
and then you realize one day you don't
even know why it's there you're carrying
all this [ __ ] you know and it's dumb
and it's irrelevant and when she said it
it was almost like I was able to drop
one piece and just go clunk there's one
piece and then when we did the podcast
it was pretty intense
it was pretty good intense but good yeah
because a Rick Ingram my co-host had no
idea sitting there in shock watching a
tennis match it's unbelievably he didn't
have any idea but here oh but it's so
crazy I don't talk about it like it
wasn't like again you evaporated so it
wasn't you weren't there I hate to say
it like that but I really wouldn't talk
about it like if somebody said I can
remember being on the road with dice and
people come on oh my god I was at the
Comedy Store do you know Bobby Lee oh
yeah and they're like he's my favorite
I'm like that's awesome yeah but I could
never say you weren't funny I couldn't
say that I do say a lot of things about
you yeah but I couldn't say that but it
was funny yeah but um and then accent
let's talk about post now yeah who the
post would help opposed you know the
year of having a friend would you call
it a friendship it's pretty hard is it
hard is it it's not hard no again I
don't think about it but it is different
ya know it's like oh [ __ ] but did you
think though that this we'd ever be
friends not really but
again I didn't ever think about it yeah
but at the same time like now when I
come in the parking lot like oh I don't
have to talk around this guy yeah I can
actually say hello yeah yeah yeah so
it's like kind of re getting to know you
yeah can I say this when I see you I
feel joy like that's kinda I wanna run
up to you yeah but it's it's funny right
oh no I don't first of all he's like a
hug but that's not everybody yeah that
makes me awkward yeah yeah or like sure
her back will be turned and a hugger
from behind yeah but I now when I see
her it's excitement and and joy which is
a miracle but it's also like it's it's a
bandage that was pulled off it should
have been like that for 20 years